president Donald Trump this was
technically in police custody today
going from processing into the
arraignment and somehow he looks even
more presidential
the brown-nosing is giving me cringe
Greg I'm sorry serious I mean we're
talking Eye of the Tiger this is why so
many people are drawn to him he fights
and by the way this is this is all
nonsense right I've seen the indictment
and it's a joke it's even sillier than
we thought I believe it is true that
Trump's arrest
helps Trump in the Republican primary
and it helps him in two ways I do
believe that there are Republicans who
have been kind of disaffected by Trump
who maybe were planning to support
someone else or not vote at all in the
primary and some of them will indeed be
activated by Donald Trump's arrest
because they've been convinced it's
unfair or whatever the case may be so
that will help Trump in the primary